hello and welcome to the 28 PHP tutorial
where we left off we were connecting to
our server and now we want to connect to
the database within our server so let's
go ahead and do that pretty simple from
there what you're going to want to do is
specify the database itself so we're
going to call this SQL DB and our SQL DB
is called epic name and then from there
we'll go ahead and come down here and
actually since we're going to call the
server and then we'll do mysql
underscore select underscored database
or DB and within their you specify the
database that you want to connect to in
our case we gave it a variable so SQL DB
and then if it can't we want to just or
die and then within the diet we wanted
to say especially since we silenced the
SQL error we got one failed to connect
to the database so from there we'll do
that and if that if both of these happen
we don't get any errors we're going to
go ahead and echo up connect I'm sorry
we already active connected so we'll
save that and put that up and actually
let's do connected because our last time
we left off with just a regular
connected so we want to make sure that
we've made progress so will refresh sure
enough we connect it with ! so now that
we've done that from here when you try
to work with a database you're going to
usually what you're going to do is
you're going to connect to your database
and you're going to use like a select so
you do select from and then you put the
table name and so that's going to vary
from time to time so what we're going to
go ahead and do so if you have a large
website chances are you're going to have
more
to pull tables within your database so
it's always best to specify that as a
case-by-case basis but for the purposes
here you're always going to be
connecting to the same database most
likely so what most people are going to
do is actually this won't be in the file
like an every PHP file that might
connect to a database instead what we're
going to do is we're going to copy this
and we're going to make a connect dot
PHP file on our service so i'm going to
do that real quick and then we'll open
that up and so that's just a blank PHP
page but what we're going to do it's
copy paste this in and this will now be
our connect dot PHP so then what we'll
do is we'll come over here after our
header we're going to go ahead and
require connect dot PHP so that's going
to require all of this code so no longer
do we need all of this code in our PHP
tutorials so we'll save both of these
and upload back to the server and just
to make sure everything went smoothly
see we got an error hold on let's see oh
right we need to get rid of this header
dot PHP or the header file within
connect so reupload that let's try one
more time there we go so now everything
worked well we're connected and we're on
the server so now let's discuss how to
kind of communicate back and forth with
database and this is going to be using
starting with select so no one will
actually begin our query so we're gonna
call um query SQL and SQL for now we're
just going to do is we're going to say
select and we're just like everything so
we raise a star sign and wrong and here
you specify the name of the table in our
case we named it epic table and be
careful these are our tildy's so the
thing above your
tab key not a you know a single quote is
it's Hildy so you select all from table
and for our purposes that's what we're
going to close it off but then there's
also like where and then you can say
like a something equals something like a
one of the categories equals something
or and then there's also ordered by and
you can order by like ID or time and
then ascending or descending but for now
we're just going to show I'm just going
to show you pulling from the database
and you know kind of displaying that
data and then also i'll show you how to
insert into a database just put the
basics so the next thing we want to do
this is like basically what we want to
query now we need to specify the actual
query itself so i said query is going to
equal a my SQL underscore query and what
we want to do is we're just going to
call SQL and then what we want to go
ahead and do is we'll just say if that
fails we'll just do or die and we're
going to say query fail and then
otherwise let's go echo query success
once we have everything set will
probably not keep spawning these success
things will just kind of only echo out
something if we fail but it's just good
for debugging purposes to make sure okay
we did get past you know we got to this
point so let me put this up and we come
over here we will fresh and sure enough
we connected and query success so since
we know our connection works and if it
doesn't we're going to die we'll go
ahead and delete this we're going to
connect dot PHP page we're just going to
change that and I'm just going to close
out of that connect now that we're done
editing it and so now we know that we've
at least made it this barks we've got
query success so now what do we do well
generally you're going to want to pull
some data excitement of selected it
now we want to do something with it so
you can almost see this as like you know
you've highlighted the information you
want but highlighting it doesn't really
do anything now let's actually look do
something so let's go ahead and call a
while loop so we'll say wow and within
here and then we'll just set it up you
know how to do a while loop within our
parameters or to specify a variable you
can call it whatever you want i'm going
to call it row because that pretty much
applies of what it is well Rho is equal
to mysql underscore fetch underscore
assoc for fetch an associative array we
want to perform the query so what this
is going to do is as long as the row
equals fetch an associative array we
want to perform the following loop so as
long as it is true because this will
this will throw a false once we've ran
out rose so as long as it's true what we
want to say is we're going to just go
ahead and say the name you can call this
anything you want but we're going to
call it name equals and then since it's
an associative array it's not denoted by
its like 0 1 2 3 it's denoted by you've
got it you've got a key in a value so
number name is going to equal row which
is talking about our array and then
we've got the key of name um the next we
have age unless going to equal row with
a key of page so each time this loops
through the information that's under the
category of name will go under the name
variable in each category CH thing
that's under the category of age will go
into the age variable and did you show
this let's echo name actually let's make
this kind of cool users
name is and then we'll add dollar mean
and then we'll say and their age is
space and will append age to that so
each time this loops through is going to
say what the person's name is and their
age and for the purposes here I've added
to two rows basically to our database so
it's going to echo out two different
rows for us and what we'll go ahead and
do let's actually also append a break to
this so we'll save that and run it and
so we see query success which we can
remove now and so now it says user's
name is Harrison and their ages 99
user's name is Jackie in their ages 55
so as you can see we've looped through
our database of information so now let
me since I got rid of that let's refresh
it again so yeah there you go so anyways
yeah that's that's reading from the
database and again you can there's also
what you could say we're say you had
like multiple entries about Harrison
like you had multiple Harrison's and you
wanted to know each Harrison's age you
could say like we're um something like
we're name equals Harrison and then you
can also order by and then if you had
time or ID you could order by ID
ascending descending and so on but for
now again we're just going to do the
basics so that's what we have so far and
in the next tutorial we'll be discussing
how to input data into a database as
always thanks for watching and until
next time